[Music]
happy monday everyone what a great show
we have to kick off this week but first
some sad news to report chris cuomo is
dead
lifting a lot of weight
now that he's unemployed
yep this dumbbell is taking his
aggressions out on the barbells
but in all seriousness our show lost an
important ally this weekend someone
who's been a hell of a supporter and
deeply involved in the success of this
program since day one you could say he
was our shining light our lodestar our
muse second banana in his own family but
number one in our hearts
[Music]
there's a lot of work put into that
in a blow that has left all of us
reeling chris cuomo was terminated from
cnn after the network allegedly just
learned that he had been accused of
sexual misconduct by a woman who had
worked with him previously at abc
yeah just learned they also just learned
the pp tapes were fake jesse smellet is
a liar and don lemon can't read
of course this tragic news is leaving a
huge hole in my show when it came to
laughs cuomo provided more than a bus
full of nitrous huffing clowns
the shock has left many of us in denial
yeah so my job just got a lot harder
having chris gone i mean the amount of
idiotic things he would say on tv made
my day so easy but not anymore
merry christmas
five thousand chris cuomo jokes we'll
never use what a waste of two hours
i think it's awesome all right now he's
gonna be able to focus all his attention
on making these shirtless workout videos
i mean these are
great
it's just that he said so many dumb
things
i just can't believe we're gonna have to
cover the news now
wait so you're saying there's not gonna
be those nightly dumbass handoffs
between him and don lemon
god what am i going to talk about
whatever
[Music]
yep
it's been a rough day for all of us
everyone here let's go to carl bernstein
tell us is this worse than watergate
what we are watching is worse than
watergate are there echoes of watergate
in this and there are we're also
witnessing something we did not see in
watergate which is a meltdown what we're
seeing
is worse than watergate yes
for once carl is right
obviously people handle the news
differently some people are weeping
others are lashing out in anger
and some are just trying to eat away the
pain
oh the crunch
[Laughter]
that never gets old
and there are others who after more
cuomo crap hit the fan happily threw him
under the bus pretending they were
always critical of his behavior
there were just so many headaches time
and time again involving chris cuomo
that even though you know many viewers
loved watching cuomo primetime and look
forward to his show he was causing so
many headaches for the network and for
cnn staffers
that ultimately this decision was
reached
yeah he says that now but you gotta hand
it to the pudgy
pontificator he puts the company man in
company manatee
case you forgot this bloated broadcaster
does a show nobody watches called
reliable sources but apparently when it
came to the chris cuomo story those
sources weren't reliable
reliable at all because he remained
silent for months on the cuomo scandals
preferring to spend his time playing
clips of fox news and complaining about
our huge ratings and now he's trying to
rewrite history meanwhile cuomo is now
claiming that zucker was aware of
everything his spokesman telling the
wall street journal owned by her parent
company the olsen twins
that chris and cnn president jeff sucker
were widely known to be extremely close
and in regular contact including about
the details of mr cuomo's support for
his brother
and now cnn's snapping back telling the
journal that cuomo has made a number of
accusations that are patently false this
reinforces why he was terminated for
violating our standards and practices
so it's about to get uglier than a sheep
with a bikini wax
but whoever wins this battle it can't
look good for cnn yep it's no longer the
most trusted name in news at regional
airports or delta terminals
even the broadcasting balloon boy
wonders has cnn lost trust as a result
of this
has cnn lost trust as a result of this
airway
well i you know i don't know that's hard
to say if cnn has lost trust he just
said it
but maybe it is hard to say i mean how
can cnn lose something they destroyed
with their own hands where is this trust
to lose after the collusion hoax the
fine people lie the injecting bleach
hoax covington kavanaugh smollette
but like newborns with a pacifier cnn is
so cute when they suck
as you know we were the first to
discover the charms of cuomo and
supported him all the way
like all these cnn clowns now angling
for his job they're despicable
as you know chris cuomo was their
highest rated host
drew that's like having the most fingers
at a leper colony
the skin biopsy i got last year drew a
larger audience than cuomo
turns out that skin tag was a honey nut
cheerio but it'd still be cuomo in the
18 to 54 year old demographic which is
important so what does this mean for the
9 pm slot who should cnn put there
i smell a nexio gutfeld in association
with jiffy lube presents
who wants to be a primetime cnn host
so what's it take to make it on cnn
other than a ton of low self-esteem or
famous parents
well turns out getting hired has nothing
to do with talent brains or even good
hair nope the less engaged you are with
the american public the more likely
you'll get hired you see cnn is not
about ratings it's about reach meaning
that the network exists only to create
angry clips of fake news which they then
disperse on the internet where its
influence is really pedaled it's like a
baseball farm team that develops talent
to send up to the major leagues where
they will be watched by a bigger
audience so instead of appeal cnn seeks
the opposite i mean let's take a look at
their current anchors
so
are you angry and petulant
are you the product of famous parents
are you miserably arrogant
are you just plain stupid
[Laughter]
do you look like you passed away 10
years ago
[Laughter]
if you feel fulfilled most of that
criteria
cnn is hiring
because like a very lazy paper boy cnn's
not interested in delivering news their
real profit model is to attract eyeballs
through conflict
think of the jerry springer show but in
tiny bite-sized servings fired like a
glitter gun into the population and the
worse you feel about america the better
they do that should be their slogan
or an uneducated consumer is our best
customer so will they find another chris
cuomo maybe we should leave cnn with
some lasting words of hope to make them
try
let's say it one more time shall we
what do you say let's get after it what
do you say let's get after it let's get
after it let's get after it it's a big
night what do you say let's get after it
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else